[Musique]
allez vite toujours plus vite en
aviation c'est le but
ultime dans cette course folle
l'Américain Charles Chuck Yager détient
un titre fort en viable première humain
a franchir le mur du son c'était le 14
octobre 1945 il y a 75 ans
[Musique]
voici le Bel X1 on dirait un obus avec
des ailes
développées par l'armée de l'air et la
Naka l'ancêtre de la NASA le prototype
est conçu pour une mission précise
franchir le mur du son volet à plus de
1200 km à l'heure
ces moteurs consomment tellement de
carburants que ceux-ci alourdissent
l'appareil rendant un décollage depuis
le sol impossible c'est pourquoi on le
largue en altitude à partir d'un autre
avion à son bord 300 kilos
d'instrumentation de quoi collecter des
données sur des événements historiques
[Musique]
au 9e vol de la journée Chuck yegger et
sa fusée atteignent 1126 km à l'heure la
vitesse du son à 10 mm d'altitude il
parvient à maintenir cette vitesse
durant 18 secondes
guerre froide oblige l'armée américaine
ne partage pas la nouvelle l'exploit
sera officialisée six mois plus tard
6 mois de silence on est loin du tapage
médiatique entourant le saut de Félix
Baumgartner filmé en direct le 14
octobre 2012
en sautant d'une altitude de 36000
mètres le parachutisme franchit le mur
du son en chute libre
et deux hommes sont désormais liés à
l'histoire du mur du son à 65 ans
d'intervalle jour pour jour